we see there's no god but allah and
muhammad is his final messenger no one's
and II know it's a sacrifice but it's a
small price to pay for all the rewards
will give from my love
what was the sisters welcome to the
house what is the house this is a brand
new show that introduced by or presented
by the Salaam studios inshallah where we
will be discussing maybe like topic this
like a little chill-out room if you
could say Judy I'm tryna say we'll be
doing reaction videos here we'll have
guests over without group discussions
where we have different audiences
inshallah
to become new join us so this specific
video is a chill-out relaxed environment
today bro what happened is basically
also not to be also Instagram about
couple of days ago I saw something
really disturbing ready to see this but
I didn't watch it in full there's a
Brahma who's on Instagram it does remind
us from New York yeah and I saw
something very abnormal where he looks
like he's ripping the shirt yeah you
know something to get brothers to do
good stuff and then all of a sudden they
into a flip so I was thinking like
what's going on with this problem here
because I like some of the stuff is
doing so I got pissed off because he say
something about tattoos buddy watch it
in full let's watch it and tell me what
if this is the first time this first
time it's not with me person so I
haven't washed it in full yet so we're
gonna watch it early because I have
tattoos but they look like what they
face in Spain and make sure got me get
off me it's him these are I'm not a
Muslim [ __ ] get that I'm not a Muslim
because I've got you
they said I'm not a mostly because I
have that you are in my own in my own
community in my own community saying
this about me because I have tattoos
fear allah fear allah fear allah I'm not
a Muslim because I have tattoos
look how ahead this person is that's
judge well I know okay
the video is very short yeah but I don't
know what's the tape on it like when you
saw that to be honest with you I feel
sorry for the brother in many ways
because like obviously he seems very
emotional
someone's told him that he's not a
Muslim because he has tattoos and so
he's obviously
switched and these things obviously if I
don't know if it's a reverb what the
situation is will convert or whatever
and he's become Muslim because that's
the thing like obviously if someone
because Muslim and there they've got
tattoos from a previous life is how
you're gonna take him off so people you
have to employ a kind of higher judgment
so especially now because a lot of
people coming into Islam so obviously is
very angry about that I would say that
at the same time if someone says to you
saying things like yeah I'm saying I
wouldn't especially in the Masjid I
would try and maintain a sin decorum
mm-hmm balanced about cuz you know what
it is it's like there's somebody said
this it's not cause that story said I
went I went to them I went to a mosque
and I was kind of shunned because I was
wearing something I never went back I
went to a bar and I spilled the alcohol
and the barman said I'll give you
another one so the mentality that would
get out of this is that for example we
have some Allah is not just cuz you
don't get enough uncle's elders where
kids don't talk don't do this don't is
this what the mission was really known
for is this way for example that you
acquire and then you're told this and
that and that's why it's really sad
because it shows that something have
really got to him for him to say that
and I would like you said before I would
say for example he's an old uncle every
yeah okay I believe now with the
messages and I've been told stuff like
[ __ ] cooze here we're just like but I
would say two things yeah he's right to
be upset
however in a Masjid and old uncle messy
they're wrong we know okay sometimes you
know what they say to me look when
certain elders reach a certain age
they're like child they become that kids
literally the psychology they become
more they get hurt easily and it that's
how it is calling someone a disbeliever
is not taller we know that hadith of
course of course comes back as one of
them and it is ignorance in a way where
if the statement is you know JA he'll
think to say but however oh if I was
person to me personally I would read her
and I would maybe walk out but maybe you
shouldn't have done that but in a
nutshell this is something that happens
not just to this prophet a lot of people
someone come with the earring we would
automatically won't even ask him is the
guy new River does he even praise Allah
automatically you know women we're okay
there's a way to advise about it and I
think this is really important for us to
address because a lot of people leave
Islam codes in this book well I mean
there's obviously a hadith in Bukhari
yeah the man who's in the Masjid and he
urinated inside of the most
exactly and there's a mushroom I cannot
remember if it's a if it's a if it's a
chapter heading actually that body put
for for this incident
the man kebab elephant Masjid yeah the
man who you know chapter of the motion
is possible if we go back to it but the
idea is that in the it was a man who
came to the message the urinated in the
Masjid and the problem how solemn he he
had a lot of mercy with him and he told
his friends to just put water over and
to kind of leave him first of all to
continue really miserable that were the
harbor at that time were were they had
an impulse to react so the Prophet so I
saw up he he calmed them down and he
told them you know just calm down you
know and put water over it he let him
finish
calm down put water over it and these
things and the man was very masha'Allah
like he was very grateful to Mohammed
Salim and he and made dua for him and
and for himself so the point is this is
a recurring theme in the biography of
the Prophet my house and the story of
his life where where it's possible to
show mercy he would show mercy and
that's what I'm a hot Bobby's at one
time it says when you if you want to be
a leader you have to be Leonor you I
read often you have to be lenient and
other than weakness so where it's not
seen as weakness be as lenient as
possible that's quite interesting well
you know even like for example the man
who came to the Prophet he said this is
isn't this imagine you're coming to the
prophet of Allah yeah and can you
imagine this father makes in a
permissible for me can you imagine the
prophet of Allah
revelations be given to another car can
you imagine if this was done today I
think people were getting killed
yeah and this is a room in tality it is
wrong to say that but sometimes you need
to understand don't just be reactional
yeah and I have this is what sometimes I
need you have that sometimes worried
about the other stuff the issue here is
that we shouldn't we should content and
I've learned this a lot I see certain
people have reaction time like if you
just calm down after not myself when I
calm down thinking through our do better
decisions then doing because in my
country they say if you stand up with
anger you said
the loss yeah so that's why it's really
important brahmins sisters for us to
understand and have mercy to other
people you do not know what's going on
in their life and one of the tattoos
that you corner somewhere a Catholic can
imagine a disbeliever I would say it
goes both ways that's who I mean by that
like hospital van having good hmm
sports assumptions about someone yeah it
goes both ways so in this a guy
shouldn't have assumed that this guy was
a non-muslim because he associates
non-muslims of tattoos yeah exactly
that could have been that could have
been a genuine since a mistake that all
is this guy a non-muslim in the message
it I wanna see what happened before I
see what you're not saying but at the
same time this brother here should have
said no listen you know I'm a Muslim but
I became most I mean it should have been
from both sides of that reaction in a
message i I don't endorse it I can't say
that shouting in the Masjid is something
which is permissible or allowed or even
if someone by the way you know says does
something to take away from your rights
yeah you know and that's something
happens all the time at least I have
respect for the Masjid not to shout and
scream in that way in the message yeah
but assume the best in the bomb it was
wrong before is do it and the same I
think both were wrong
probably sisters to be honest that's
about it we just wanted to watch this
video and gain some benefits from
because as you guys know especially
especially the house this film that we
have here and the reaction videos that
we do we don't just do it just to show
you and say oh wow
it's actually to benefit from these
stuff and that's what we're going to be
doing and you know what actually was
when an amazing series coming up about
tusky inshallah which we're gonna do in
a really unique way which you guys some
people it might be a bit controversial
as we know that initially it's gonna be
beneficial but my sisters from the house
with brother muhammad hijab the host
bide we were to both kiss here so it's a
lot but this is the chilla the house so
we've got a no shots coming up in
Shalala don't forget to subscribe and
watch more for this and also support our
cause there's a lot on the link below
this is not real fire by the way just
well you know i said i wanna come into
my Medicare